is she just being Miley or is Miley
Cyrus doing the lilo yeah Miley took to
her Instagram story to sing along to
Lindsay Lohan 2004 hits rumors and in a
way this is the former teen screen
collab of my dream it's pretty good guys
it's amazing do the lilo buy them I am
NOT gonna do though but you should do it
okay well it's so good Miley also tagged
Lindsay in the video and Lindsay has now
responded reposting the vid on her story
writing love you
yep so it's a new Hollywood friendship
blossoming because it's all comes just
after Miley gave a glowing review to
Lindsey's MTV series Lindsay Lohan
speech club yep and after a media outlet
tarnished the show Miley came to its
defense calling it the best show ever
an exaggeration or accurate I think it
might be a little accurate yeah it's so
good um although I love this new
friendship I feel like they both grew up
in the spotlight they have that Disney
past absolutely so much in common I love
both of these ladies any friendship in
Hollywood where they support each other
I am here for me too so one question
though
do you think that there's also some
subliminal messaging since the song
rumors is all about being tired of fake
stories coming out and Miley just had to
debunk that she was pregnant okay I mean
that is a take and I'm glad that she
cleared those rumors
it could be hurting her new little Bop
it could be heard no little Bobby I
could see it but what do we think though
when it comes to Miley and Liam they
seem to be really happy as newlyweds
enjoying that newlywed life in fact et
was with Liam over the weekend take a
look at what he said it's the best it's
the best it's um you know I feel so
lucky to be with someone like her and
yeah it's
very very very lucky ah there's some
Plano they are adorable we've been
waiting for this to happen for a long
time you know newlywed bliss looks good
on them yeah um one thing I will point
out though Lyndsey was not so happy with
Miley years ago for this SNL moment I
never stole a necklace or got it do you
I never cheated on my wife like that the
gulper guy so what you can see a little
boob from the side I'm sorry that I'm
not perfect
yikes yeah at that time there were
reports Lyndsey even sent a letter to
SNL head honcho Lorne Michaels letting
him know she was upset by that monologue
and I understand why I'm just glad
that's all in the past you up with Miley
and Lindsay have a lot going for them
right now
Miley of course just put out a new song
nothing breaks like a heart I'm good
Lindsay has her new MTV show and a new
movie coming out what's happening for
the lady I just wish that Lindsay would
also put out new music she told et
that's not gonna happen but maybe she
would reconsider now like a collab I
don't know I think she's gonna let her
sister shine but in our dreams that will
be the collab that happens yeah let's
give you guys one more look at that
instant video because it is so good oh
good
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
underscore Kraus and I'm at Kourtney
underscore teza know bye for now
[Music]